he's brigade are on fire but at his
hectic pace it's vital that every member
of the team is on top of every detail
this is the vegetarian wood sandy stop
stop stop
coconut cream there's no coconut cream
later brother before we take anything
you got a teller
stare Chavez control here isn't it so
you're taking dishes she doesn't know is
gone one lamb cutlets as well guys and
that's all the start has done for
everybody then sandy thinks all the
starters are out but a quick scan of the
dining room reveals he's missed a whole
table however that was your spicy haggis
lamb Curtis sandy are you missing an
order all the tables are taken here
that's front of house boss sandy should
be all over this so that's that's all
gone a fun one yeah so this yeah no
that's all gone yes yeah I took my c3
there but there for now
smells nice can taste of West Muslims
yes okay no prob to see threes as
opposed to see two
and you don't help as when you take food
don't tell her where he's got it and I'm
just the fly in the ointment
okay here joy
at last the missing table get their food
okay okay man cost me at all bris whilst
bees kitchen ramps up for the mains
Sandy's front-of-house team seemed more
and more disorientated we've got more
waiters in here now than we have chef is
that one more lambs here cheer we're
going sandy son looks a little bit so
lost there Johnny yeah you know buddy
comes in a little bit yeah
face you're like this but just like to
like to be out right way so you handle
pressure better than he does
despite his confusion standards got
nearly all the main courses and deserves
out with 45 minutes to spare
and it's soon clear how he's done it
it's a bit weird she's eating her - ser
while I'm having my mean I don't think
we expected that when we ordered it you
know woman you ordered I thought you
don't you start over then have a meal
together short it's best to serve the
starter yeah
gap main course gap and then dessert but
we thought rather than somebody sit
there eating what the partner has
nothing for 20 minutes it was less human
for somebody to be eating at the same
time I know that's personally how I
would prefer it it does make sense no I
agree haven't seen it so far in the
competition okay last table cut out guys
today being a kitchen team really have
scored a hole-in-one
I went for the Thai vegetarian haggis
which was really exquisite with British
fantastic start to finish it was
delicious renal socks off after the
field really I'm a father it was good
worth waiting for privileges with such
fantastic food the wheat link here is
clearly front-of-house I spoke to the
diners and not everybody enjoyed having
their dessert and the main course at the
same time dessert is a sort of sweet
grand finale not to be eaten opposite a
duck the saving grace today is that
everyone loved the food that's for me
the most important sign up get the
service as good as a food in 99 percent
of the way there